donc la lettre c'est quoi cette lettre
Diomi elle a elle a fait une lettre où
elle dit à à Alain Delon que elle que le
plus beau cadeau qu'il pourrait lui
faire c'est lui donner son son nom en
fait elle sait qu'elle est en danger
elle lui demande de de de de de de la
sécuriser financièrement donc elle est
très insistante et elle veut que Alain
Delon lespousse chose qu'il refusera
toujours et encore jusque au 5 juillet
où elle a été expulsée de de douchi très
bien d'accord on va accueillir euh
chaque Carau secondes un petit peu
retard mer Monera la suite du point
pipul demain puisque on va parler de
complément d'enquête puisque complément
d'enquête est encore déprogrammé jeudi
les chériis encore déprogrammé jeudi
apparemment ça chauffe chez France
Télévision puisque on va parler des
images de complément d'enquête d'avec
Gérard pardu mais juste avant plusieurs
numéros de complément d'enquête ont été
suspendus notamment ce sur Gabriel hatal
Rachid adati Alexis CER le secrétaire
général général de l'isé
euh je crois que ça commence à devenir
compliqué et car le directeur
deinformation Che frvision a demandé aux
journalistes travaillant sur les
magazines complément donê envoyé spécial
13h15 de faire une pause jusqu'aux
élections européennes ça c'est normal
mais jaces card va nous en dire un peu
plus là-dessus je me demande si ma
prédiction n'était pas la bonne
rappelez-vous je vais vous dire la
vérité ce complément d'enquête et je
vous le dis ce soir vous allez voir ils
vont le faire ce sera la fin de
complément d'enquête derrière parce que
je vais mettre mon nez dedans et vous
savez que quand je mets mon nez quelque
part généralement je fais souvent tout
péter ce que je peux dire juste à France
Télévision prépareer juste un rideau
parce que à mon avis appeler un rideau
métallique parce que je pense que ça va
être la catastrophe dans moins d'un mois
alors j'ai pas raison sur le le temps le
tempo hein malheureusement mais
compléments d'enquête ça sent le rousi
Jacques cardose ça sent pas bon pour
complément d'enquête apparemment la
direction de France Télé aimerait mettre
ce magazine en tout cas sous été noir
pour l'instant ce qui est sûr c'est
c'est que Delphine Hernot elle va avoir
une décision présidente de France
Télévision une décision très importante
à prendre compte tenu des éléments que
pourrait apporter l'avocat ce soir c'est
évidemment la marque qui pourrait
décrédibilisé mais si si là ce soir non
mais attends Jacques carard je vais dire
mon Jacques si ce soir il montre que les
imagesoué c'est même pas la peine on en
parle même plus c'est fini et là c'est
scandale auion mais déjà l'émission
c'est sûr que c'est fini options par
rapport à ça le président de France
Télévision enfin la présidente en
l'occurrence soit elle veut préserver la
marque ce cas doit changer l'équipe qui
est en place peux plus c'est fini soit
effectivement si elle conserve sa
confiance en l'équipe qui est en place
moi je crains que ce soit quand même
très compliqué pour eux de conserver de
la crédibilité c'est fini la marque la
marque elle est terminé l'équipe et la
marque les deux l'équipe et la marque
c'est fin m même elle risque quelque
chose bien sûr alors je vais t'expliquer
ce qui se passe si ça se passe et on va
voir les images dis dans 5 minutes
maintenant il va arriver Jérémy Assous
je sais que vous les attendez fortement
ces je t'explique c'est le diffuseur qui
est
responsable ah c'est elle qui
responsable une PL c'estcoute bien ride
tout leonde ce soir sil a vraiment n
encore la possibilité de diligentter une
enquête d'essayer de savoir on
Troms on s'en fout je t'explique tu es
responsable moi moi je t'explique quand
on a pris les 3 millions d'euros
d'amende la chaîne elle a pas digenté
une enquête on a vu que cétait
responsable là ce qui va nous montrer ce
soir apparemment Jérémi Assous l'avocat
de yanx c'est image par image on va voir
si ça a été truqué ou pas si on est
convaincu nous ici et que le les
téléspectateurs sont convaincus par ces
preuves que ça a été effectivement
magouillé et qu'ils ont mis Gérard
pardieu dans une sauce en plus qui
n'était pas la sienne et qu'ils ont
trafiqué les images et qui lui ont fait
dire quelque chose sur une jeune fille
alors que c'était pas sur elle là et je
t'explique il y a pas d'enquête il y a
plus rien je t'explique ces démissions à
tous les étages à France Télévision je
suis désolé de te dire ça excuse-moi
jacqu moi je pense qu'il y a encore un
moyen de de sauver la marque mais ça va
dépendre de ça non mais jaces arrête de
dire des bêtises excuse-moi je t'adore
jacqu parce que tu parce que tu penses à
beno duen qui était exceptionnel qui a
lancé la marque complément d'enquête et
qui mais là tu parles avec ton cœur mais
parles avec ta tête là tu parles en Gill
Verdez excuse-moi non mais parle avec
tte jeis attaché je suis attaché à la
marque tout ce que j'ai dit sur
complément c'est justement parce que
j'ai pas envie de la voir disparaître
que j'ai pas envie
qu'elleout aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les
infos elles sont simples c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tu vois bien qu'ils ont
annulé alors sous prétexte des élections
européennes ils en annulent énormément
là ce je ils ont profité des agricur
pour dire qu'il y avait une spéciale
donc ils annulent encore complément
d'enquête je t'explique nous ici il peut
y avoir n'importe quoi on nna jamais PP
d'autant plus qu'ils ont fait des
audiences très très bonnes dernièrement
exaementou les audiences les ont tué les
audiences les ont tué parce qu'ils ont
voulu faire du buzz et ils savent pas
faire ils ont été dans un terrain qui
n'était pas le leur ils sont allés sur
un terrain qu'ils ne connaissent pas
Fran télvision et qui ne savent pas
gérer derrière nous ici et je le dis
voilà bu on en fait depuis 12 ans depuis
13 ans ça fait 12 ans qu'on est toujours
entêté qu'on est toujours regardé et
pied on sait faire on a des situations
de crise on connaît eux le problème ils
sont allés sur un terrain qui n'est pas
le leur et forcément quand tu vas sur un
terrain qui n'est pas le tien et ben
quand tu as pas fait du skip pendant 3
ans et que tu vas faire direct du hor
piste et ben frérot et ben tu te
retrouves sur le culule alors sur sur
les numéros qui ont été déprogrammés
c'est assez dingue comme histoire parce
que lorsqu'on est à la tête d'une
émission comme celle-là on sait très
bien que 5 à 6 mois avant une élection
tu t'engages pas dans une dans une
enquête politique parce que il y a le
décompte des temps de parole j'ai
regardz il y a une vingtaine de listes
qui sont candidates pour les européennes
si tu fais 60 minutes sur le Paris sur
quelqu'un de la majorité présidentielle
alors il faut faire 60 minutes 20 fois
donc c'est ingérable dans le temps impti
déjà c'est une erreur profession déjà
c'est une erreur c'est presque une faute
professionnelle de la part de la
direction de complément d'enquête qui
lance forcément Gabriel les rachidti
sont des enquêtes qui ont été lancées
depuis la nomination de l'un et de
l'autre donc là ça 15 jours ou 3
semaines il savaient pertinemment à 5
mois de la présidentielle que ça pouvait
pas passer et donc la position
d'Alexandre Cara directeur de l'info
elle est juste normale il peut pas se
permand car qui qui nouvellement il a
été il est patron depuis 6 mois je crois
6 mois voilà qui est très bon d'ailleurs
Alexandre car je l'avais sur avec moi il
est très bon et lui pour lui c'est un
caillou dans sa chaussure excuse-moi on
c'est aujourd'hui complémentux il a été
né il était très inquiet de la tournure
des magazines puisque bon on avait
échangé là-dessus mais franchement
là-dessus j'ai vu ici ou là des
critiques en disant c'est de
l'autocensure non c'est pas de
l'autocensure lui il a juste le respect
strict des temps de parole avec les
partis politiques à à à à respecter et
il se respecte par tranche horaire
c'est-à-dire que tu peux pas compenser
en mettant le parti du chien à 3h du
matin c'est c'est tu es obligé de mettre
les 20 partis entre 23h et minuit tous
les jeudis donc c'est ingérable
là-dessus il pouvait pas faire autrement
à tel point Cyril que je me pose la
question de savoir si
c'est une minute maintenant Jérémy Assou
sera avec nous
pourer les images de Gérard pardieu pour
voir si elles ont ét bien trafiqué ou
pas sachez que je dois lancer les images
on va vous montrer image par image les
preuves qu'il aurait et si ça a été
trafiqué forcément je te dis Jacques tas
beau être attaché à cette marque la
marque c'est terminée et cévision
derrière ça va être très très compliqué
tu voulais rajouter quelque chose juste
une chose pour finir là-dessus c'est que
Tristan Wex et Hugo Plard savaient très
on va Rapp qui
estistage qui sort tu sais Tristan il
est connu que par 9% des Français il y a
un sondage qui va sortir là ou 15 %
voilà donc il faut arrêter de dire
Tristan ou Alex comme si c'était
alainon te dis il y a un sondage qui va
sortir là sur la notoriété des
personnalités de télévision je te dis
qui va sortir là je te le dis Tristan
Alex il a 9% je crois si mes souvenirs
sont exacts donc il faut dire qui c'est
parce que triston Wex personne ne
connaît triston Wex on croit que c'est
un collège donc en tous les cas c'est
c'est c'est eux Wex et Planard qui ont
décidé de lancer ces deux enquêtes
sachant très bien à à 6 mois de la de la
des européennes que ce serait
extrêmement compliqué et surtout ça
fuite dans la presse mais ça fuite dans
la presse Cyril si ça fuite dans la
presse c'est je me demande à quel point
c'est pas un piège et une peau de banane
lancé à la direction de l'info c'est pas
très élégant je trouve que quand tu as
une affaire comme celle-là tu la gardes
pour toi tu la balances pas à la press
donc ça ça je trouve que c'est assez
assez maladroit moi je pense qu'il y a
encore une façon et un moyen de sauver
la marque et j'espère que la
marque mais arrête avec ça non mais
arrête avec ça tu nas pas ici pour nous
dire on va sauver la marque tu vois bien
ce qu'il va te montrer là tu vas pas
sauver la marque sauf la marque de ta
chemise mais sauve pas la marque de la
tu vois bien que tu es fini non mais ne
fais pas fais pas fais pas fais pas le
CH Verdez non mais sans déconner
excuse-moi ne va pas défendre
l'indéfendable tu vois bien que là mon
chéri je t'aime beaucoup mais là tu
défends l'indéfendable est-ce que Jérémy
Assous est prêt s'il vous plaît c'est ce
qu'on PE tout le monde me dit tu dis ça
tu es argneux contre complément
d'enquête et Cera moi j'ai décidé de
quitter cette je le redis c'est je veux
dire personne m'a mis le le couteau sous
voilà je dire je suis parti j'ai quitté
France Télévision avec très très peu
d'argent je le précise
auss voilà et je l'ai fait aussi pour
des questions de conviction parce que je
n'étais plus d'accord avec un certain
nombre de choix et je suis pas très
étonné qu'ils en arrivent là aujourd'hui
alors